I
good afternoon my name is Daniel Campos
and I'm a participant from the first
class of the Columbia University Kenneth
Cole community engagement program before
I begin I would like to thank mr. Cole
first vision and support for this
program having just completed it myself
I know that I'll change the lives of
many young inspiring activists like
myself so again thank you it is an honor
and a privilege today to introduce you
the second panel which is been titled
advocating for a just community creating
new pathways to justice this panel will
be addressing a problem that
underprivileged communities are
particularly likely to face which has
access to legal justice on the one hand
we're facing an issue concerning the
justice system itself as these
communities have to face institutions
that are slow unaffordable intimidating
unnecessarily complex and potentially
even biased or discriminatory further
there's a second problem surrounding
education as other barriers or justice
can occur when individuals are not aware
of their own rights in court pleading to
unfair rulings this is a very
complicated yet pertinent issue that our
group of expert panelists will be
addressing for you all today but before
we get into the meat of the panel I
would like to speak to you a bit about
my experience in the kenneth cole
community engagement program and the
summer internship experience that served
as the inspiration for today's panel
discussion my interest in the kenneth
cole community engagement program is
done from a desire to advocate for
policy that affects disadvantaged
communities prior to my experience in
the kenneth cole program much of my
energy had been spent promoting national
policy advocating for the DREAM Act here
at Columbia and working at the White
House Office of Public Engagement to
create and coordinate direct dialogue
between the Obama administration and
Latino Native American leaders on
national policy these were experiences
that affirmed my life commitment to
social justice but a dawned on me that
I'd actually spent very little time in
the community as i was hoping to serve
the chemical program seemed to be the
perfect opportunity for me as they allow
me to work in local communities and
personally launch an initiative that
will promote social change through the
chemical program i was placed in an
organization called legal information
today also known by the acronym lift
lift is a nonprofit organization that
works to enhance access to justice for
children and families by providing free
legal information to unrepresented
litigants in the family court system I
learned that a family court few people
are entitled to receive free
court-appointed attorneys and because
the majority of litigants in the family
courts are low-income they cannot afford
an attorney of their own thus
individuals are forced to represent
themselves often without an
understanding of their legal rights and
with little understanding of the family
court system families can lose the
opportunity to obtain an appropriate
legal response to their probe for their
problems and this will often lead to
poor outcomes for families and children
the lift has a very strong presence in
the family court houses in all five
boroughs they were looking to increase
its presence on the community level in
order to reach people who we were told
may fall through the cracks my fellow
interns and I were tasked with creating
to grassroots outreach campaigns the
neighborhood in the Bronx and a
neighborhood in Brooklyn and then use
our lessons learned to create an
outreach strategy for left our findings
would be crucial in helping left
effectively expand its reach and help a
broader base of people my experiences
working these neighborhoods had an
impact in my life in multiple ways but
the most profound lesson I learned that
summer was the power of the individual
to create social change when working in
these communities the average human I
became increasingly aware of the many
challenges that were involved in
establishing resources and communities
no two neighborhoods are alike and as
such there is no static mold for
effective outreach reaching people
requires unique expertise in the
characteristics of the community and
knowledge of the people of a community
as such effective grassroots change
really stems from the hands of a
passionate few individuals who dedicate
themselves to their communities during
my welcome at many local leaders and
activists who had devoted their lives to
the communities they lived in I realized
that though national policies can affect
a broad group of people that real
profound social change starts here at
the grassroots level with these
individuals these are the people who are
creating pathways to justice one such
individual who's creating pathways to
justice through investigative journalism
is the moderator of today's panel Chris
Cuomo mr. Cuomo's a co-anchor of 2020 DM
award-winning ABC news magazine and he's
also the chief law and justice
correspondent for ABC News at2020 Cuomo
has been a champion of purposeful
long-form journalism his hour-long
documentaries exposed the growing number
of homeless teens in America and a
groundbreaking look at the new face of
heroin his investigative efforts have
been a cornerstone of ABC News get
answers series tackling dozens of cases
against major companies that have often
resulted in real change in exposing
these instances of social injustice mr.
Cuomo has literally created social
change for the lives of the
disadvantaged mr. Cuomo will now
introduce the panelists who will each
have their turn to address the audience
we will then transition to a panel
discussion followed by a question and
answer session so without further ado
please help me in welcoming this
inspiring man of the moderator for our
panel this afternoon mr. mr. Cuomo
thank you for bullying this is good
opportunity there aren't too many people
which means you're going to be able to
interact more with people who can really
enlighten you about what can make a
difference on this issue obviously very
important for a lot of reasons and you
understand that I see it a different way
I tell the stories I understand the
situations I really am able to change
them each of the people up here on this
panel spends their time understanding
but also figuring out how to change
whether it's through an intellectual
construct as professor shed is going to
talk about or obviously you have angel
rodriguez and Ben Jealous who deal with
the problems every day on different
levels about how to create justice in a
community and what the challenges are so
this is a good opportunity for you
hopefully you will have to hear from me
very little which means you guys have
good questions you are driving us you
have things that you want answered
perspective it you want fill them then
you have great people to do that so each
will come up make a little presentation
let you know what brought them to this
panel and then we'll start our
discussion okay we're going to start
with Carla shed you should know her
already because she teaches at your
school assistant professor of sociology
and african-american studies here also
taught me the word carceral today which
has been very this has already been
valuable to me so professor sheds go
we're going to come up show you some
slides introduce a little bit of the
context for today please say hello
good afternoon everyone I'm delighted to
be here thank you so much for the
invitation and clinical for providing
this wonderful opportunity for us to
discuss our work and to talk about
pathways to justice today I want to talk
a bit about the other 99 percent and
discussing my work on race place and
perceptions of injustice so there is no
a resounding call for human rights
movement that will respond to the damage
that mass incarceration has done to the
collective realization of our American
ideals of opportunity fairness and
equality top-down policy reform is only
the beginning of this movement to
radically restructure America's approach
to criminal justice and the
intergenerational transmission of
inequality should be at its center
Michelle Alexander amongst many others
reminds us that the human rights
movement that dr. Martin Luther King jr.
believed had revolutionary potential
would happen only if we raise certain
basic questions about our entire society
I argue that our nation's criminal
justice system and how we treat the most
vulnerable who are ensnared and its
ever-expanding grasp is the standard by
which we should get our realization of
these ideals of American democracy and
justice as in urban sociologist I
explore the experiences of marginalized
individuals groups and communities in
the US and their interactions with
social institutions that can
simultaneously ameliorate or perpetuate
social inequality i explicitly
investigate how race and plays shape
youth perceptions of injustice because
if we're going to talk about the
question of advocating for justice we
need to have a perception that there's
injustice present and in framing this
discussion I wanted to give voice and
my comments with a little bit of
interview data from one of the students
I talked to on the south side of Chicago
when I did my graduate level research in
exploring this question of perceptions
of injustice and he essentially links
these ideas of social mobility and
opportunity directly to physical
mobility David tells me that he believes
that being black makes it harder for him
to find a good place to live and nice
place to live excuse me and to find a
good job he explains it's not mostly
blacks in the world I see many whites
and movies and stuff I see all this
stuff on TV at the time when I
interviewed him there was no Barack
Obama he says there was never a black
president and when my on and Grandma and
try to get a job most of the people that
are managers they're white or mexican
you don't find black people with
ownership and only but a few places he
says I don't have a fair chance because
every time I go outside a couple of days
ago I was just walking down the street
and the police pulled me over and
checked me for no apparent reason after
they checked me they found ten dollars
and an asthma pump and they said have a
nice day and rode off and I asked what
do you think about the police after
seeing this and experiencing this he
says they shouldn't be doing this they
need to see what a person is doing first
not just walk up on them check them I
didn't do anything wrong they just
pulled me over check me ask me my name
and address they weren't writing it down
they just asked me I don't know why this
has happen often to other kids your age
he says yes every time I walk I'll be
seeing people get checked black people
going to jail every day so the question
might be for me how do schools and
neighborhoods socialize young people to
the criminal justice system and argue
that there's a new sort of
normal that they're dealing with and
where does it start how do you plant the
seed one might be the fact that from two
thousand six until 2010 this gel
playground remained on the grounds of
the tompkins projects in Brooklyn people
play it on it walk by it every day but
it was only when the national attention
of the New York Times and other media
outlets came that they actually took it
down so for young people growing up in
this community it means a bit something
different if we're seeing this gel
playground and if they also know that
their neighborhood is one of the biggest
pathways to the criminal justice system
sending many people to prison every
every day empirical evidence thanks to
the work of sociologists like Becky Peck
Pettit and Bruce Weston reveals that
imprisonment has become a common life
event for african-american males in
particular more common than even college
or military service in the last decade
one-third of black men without college
education had gone to prison by their
early 30s for blackmail high school
dropouts the risk of imprisonment
increased to sixty percent thus
incarceration is a normal stopping point
in the course of these men's lives and
the next generation of African American
males is not poised to do better in
light of these dismal race gender
education interaction effects as we call
them in sociology the high school
graduation rate in our nation's 50
largest cities is only about fifty three
percent a most recent graduation rate
for black males in New York City was
estimated to be only twenty-eight
percent so we all pay the cost when the
school to Prison Pipeline are better get
out of school to Prison Pipeline has a
tight grasp on our children therefore we
must acknowledge that it is race
combined with gender
class age demeanor and place that
determines who is and who it's not
ensnared into ever-expanding web of
police control because the social
distribution of the justice systems
impact is not evenly distributed mass
incarceration is a phenomenon that is
experienced locally follows a stable
pattern and can be systematically
predicted by key social characteristics
like racial isolation poverty
unemployment family disruption even
after controlling for levels of crime in
the community resulting in a vicious
read self-reinforcing cycle for instance
in 2008 this is according to some data
that was actually for presented by the
n-double-a-cp in a recent recent report
more than fifty percent of the people
sent to just tune to prison in New York
City held from 27 of the city's 200 zip
codes only eighteen percent of the
city's adults reside in those areas so
to further think about how much place
matters I like for us to really
understand the implications of
stop-and-frisk which I know probably
bought a lot of people to this panel and
their questions about the contemporary
movements going on today if we can think
of these practices before the current
movement we see actually the New York
Times highlighted that in Brownsville
Brooklyn within the perimeter of about
eight blocks from 2006 to 2010 the NYPD
made 52,000 stops this is an area for
two thousand residents and
african-american Mills
will bear the burden of these policies
52,000 stops less than 1% of them ending
in arrest we should be concerned about
the impact of this kind of policing
particularly on the remaining ninety
nine percent who are subjected to this
extremely invasive and overtly
criminalizing experience and the
surveillance does not end there many of
the same young people who are used to
being stopped and frisked in their
neighborhoods are often subjected to
similar practices at schools schools and
for those who live in public housing
even homes have come to resemble
correctional facilities now standard are
metal detectors surveillance cameras and
other mechanisms designed to monitor and
control their inhabitants and you can
must navigate these spaces are
inevitably at high risk of police
contact which may lead to frustration
disengagement and perhaps even
delinquency thus young people are
introduced to the criminal justice
system without setting foot in a jail or
a courtroom now is the time to take
stock of the potentially devastating
consequences these practices are having
on urban communities at large and this
is one of the schools I study in Chicago
where right next to a sign that says
children first building for our future
you see upon entering the building you
would be subject to search and it's
every day that young people are padded
down and going into the school you also
see the kind of recognition that police
should be protecting students but in
many of the interviews that I did young
people sort of laughed at this and said
I wouldn't call the police if I actually
wanted protection and these are main
representatives of the justice system
this is sort of who begins to socialize
our young people to justice so what are
the consequences of of this work two
things you shape will reviews police are
the most direct link between law
enforcement and the pub
and these contacts are happening at a
formative period when young people are
beginning their ideas about life and
they're sort of motivations and it
shapes their outcomes so you shape your
views and you then shape life
trajectories and stop-and-frisk in
particular it's the beginning of what
may be repeated contacts at deeper and
deeper levels of the criminal justice
system for these young black and brown
men in particular so one thing we must
do is examine the fundamental
relationship black people brown people
have with the state this is one in which
the government provides so many needs
from housing to schooling welfare mass
incarceration Latinos are now the
majority in our federal prisons due to
changes in immigration policy and
enforcement what might these procedures
would stop and frisk and beyond mean for
channeling more Latinos into the
criminal justice system hi employer
unemployment amongst these populations
50% youth unemployment nearly twenty
percent black male unemployment we must
make these connections public education
high school dropouts are the base
population of the criminal justice
system and generally what is the
geography of inequality or the geography
of opportunity in the different cities
in which we are raising these urban
youth we must feed of all these factors
as contributing to the symptoms that
these policies like stop-and-frisk were
created to address but the underlying
social conditions are central and must
be part of this conversation so in
conclusion the research that I've just
briefly described and these points
extend beyond Chicago New York City's
borders to other areas where opportunity
is distributed via zip code American
teenagers are the guinea pigs for an
enormous
experiment and how we create our fail to
create a citizenry that feels safe and
has faith in its country's institutions
we must reckon with the attitudes and
experiences of young people today
because they in turn will have the
greatest effect in shaping the state of
our America Thanks alright so good
perspective on laying out the issues and
what should be taken into consideration
we're going to try to evaluate what it
is to create justice in a community
especially the communities we're
discussing today mr. Angel Rodriguez
works with an organization here locally
that has to deal with the realities on
the ground of everything the professor
just laid out so a good building block
for the questions you'll have afterwards
please angel come on Angel Rodriguez
could be put on the video
I'd say far as it is
grepolis community with many issues my
mother was my alcoholic sniff coke on
regular
i left my house at ten my mother bought
to look for me never bother to ask
somebody where with that she was too
caught up in her drugs liquor at the
time to know where we bought our zone I
just wish she'd just worked a little
harder what's for me when I was missing
this month yeah listen 11-year old
daughter are keeping better I'm so Joyce
from 11 to 16 crack cocaine though
whatever I will get my hands on I so did
my schedule
years was smoked marijuana gejra sell
drugs go shopping
for years my schedule I was in the past
where I was going
braylon jail two options when your
histories jail okay my first of us was
ground wrestling second arrest was a
direct sale and then my third arrest was
observation sale stating that Detective
seen selling I was facing a three to six
these charge was one and a half or three
years and that's well then brother
she was known to us in a community when
his arrest gangbang is when Drew
ultimately really engage with her to try
to change a lot aside from her
being arrested and indicted
different charges there came a very
short time after that where she
discovered that she was pregnant facing
time cloning was the scariest thing ever
knowing that you might get birth to your
children um prison facility
understanding that she was pregnant I
think they were another reality check
that was maybe a turning point so great
degree when she realized that she was
going to have to do something again to
get out of a cycle but she and her
parents were the Anjou gravity program
is a alternative in conservation program
which own basically gay
adolescents second chances I life which
they gave me angel rodriguez is
executive director of energy level he
makes sure that you are doing what
you're supposed to do highest person to
it and when you're supposedly
I was giving curfew I was to call him
soon as I behind he will come with me to
my place at school to get me back at
school he was to attend to all my court
dates here we yell at you when you need
to yell at you
you hug you when you need to be hooked
and he'll be his shoulder knees crying
for the road or the support all the time
the effort that you put in me well he
never gave up on me
LT is about to graduate college she does
have a full-time job and of course she's
a wonderful
and i think the web was kind of opening
a far i am just thrilled to be part of
that process my was where these are
better but i produced try my best
and ice machine do together I tell my
daughter I love you every day in the
morning before she goes she knows she
needs to be loved like any other parent
of ancient wine wanted better for her
child and that's a basis that I use a
lot because it's about billing cycles
mine on one dream is to get back as well
as I was giving
for this kind of moment of people who
beat the odds and forward
she's done
I made it I'm just so
their life since died but it was first
time that I went through
the review program was going on brother
making sure we get wet
thank you I brought that video hoping
that there would be as I was told a lot
of students here hoping to motivate some
of them to stop thinking about a
different picture and realities was
going on our criminal justice system I
had been working diligently to develop
an organization that's in the trenches
on the criminal justice system as we are
in the trenches of some of our poor
communities in indo Glover my intent and
creating this program was to have a
global program in every community with
its poverty where young people need
assistance especially those who
unfortunately fall into a criminal
justice system and unfortunately 211
2011 I thought we would be in a
different place where young people will
be striving with education and
employment and all the wonderful things
that they deserve unfortunately we are
in a different place today where there
are more young people hitting our system
Hindu global engages in our family court
I go to Family Court where I have a lot
of concerns because i feel that while
society and everyone believes that our
kids rights are being protected i find
that the family court system to some
degree doesn't do that not for kids of
color and i must say that my experience
and i welcome anybody who wants to walk
into that system is that every single
child that you see in any of our court
cords weather is the family court our
adult court in our youth part that
that's being created ninety-nine percent
of them are black or Hispanics and I
think there's a problem with that that
i'm not sure why spear looked at thank
God by other people that I am grateful
for us at their dressing policy as it
relates to at what wait stopping
stopping first many of the issues that
are impacting our system
amber Glover on a 24 hour days
supervises a lot of kids that are
referred to us by lawyers by mothers by
community agencies I'm different than
other a TI is attorney to incarceration
programs that work within our system the
sad part is that I can count them on one
hand and yet we have thousands of kids
that are falling through the cracks of
our system a little Glover will pick up
about 300 kids a year and there are so
many kids that are falling by the
wayside and what we provide is our
support and global is the agency that's
called by the parent when our detective
knocks on your door and says I'm looking
for your son of your daughter Frank
colon comes to us from that parent and
we then called the detectives and find
out what they may want traditionally it
is an open 61 or in order to arrest on a
criminal case we endow global ones up
engaging in cases even before the system
does in that we surrender the kid to the
detective potentially and preserved
their Miranda warnings and make sure
that again the person is not questioned
about the incident until he has an
attorney Andrew Glover was a police
officer was shot and killed in the line
of duty in the lower east side where
again a lot of poverty communities is
where the police department sets up all
their their programs that they try out
to see whether they work on at and
operation pressure point initiated in a
lower east side and expanded through a
lot of our poor communities and
incarcerated a lot of young people as it
in this particular case integral I was
actually shot and killed by kids who had
drugs and guns in a car and global cared
about kids and would call us and say
maybe we can keep that young person from
that revolving door which is what we do
our program is embedded in the system I
am a private identity in that I don't
take government money I raised my money
privately to do this and I don't like
saying that because I think the
government has a stake and the
government should be supporting and
helping in his areas of prevention so
that young people perhaps don't knock on
the doors of the criminal justice system
that is costing enormous amount of money
I my numbers are for 2,900 dollars i can
keep the kid in the community well a
system is spending about our $250,000 to
incarcerate in places that are mostly
dealing with punishment and I'm talking
about the adult system the family court
system is a different animal even though
the numbers are probably the same or
sometimes even more because those
youngsters require the social workers
and teams of people who work with them
the rest of the young people
unfortunately are in our Rikers Island
and city jails or state prisons and
they're they're not getting a lot of
support years ago young people used to
be able to address education and
training which I thought is the way to
go we're going to incarcerate somebody
for two three four or five ten years
that we should provide a way that when
they come back to the community that can
be a productive person rather than a
better criminal which is unfortunately
what happens in some of these
institutions in the process of surviving
end o globo operates one o'clock is
known to all the judges in a family
court in a criminal court and mostly I
hate to say the Supreme Court because a
lot of these young kids are indicted of
a drop of a hat and in the Supreme Court
we're dealing with very serious issues
and convictions of course I engaged with
a lot of 13 through 21 22 year olds the
population that's hitting our system
right now and you guys read in a paper
every single day
14 15 16 17 18 year olds the system
doesn't allow for a lot of protection if
you're under the age of 8 19 you can be
adjudicated I can negotiate with it
directly with a judge in a Supreme Court
pod and be able to work out a
probationary period with an adjudication
of the criminal record if you are 19
years old you cannot get adjudicated and
if the case carries jail time that's
what propositioned and there's a lot of
work being done legislature looking at
these issues to bump up the age of that
I'd unification to 21 I work a lot of
care to a twinning and they have the
same mentalities they hang out with the
same kids but the legal responsibility
is so much more and once young person
becomes the age of my team when you are
a quadroon negotiating a case judges
have no real power to do anything other
than perhaps adjust to the prosecutor or
maybe they should listen to someone like
me to come down on a possible plea and
it gives the prosecutor's office a lot
of power unfortunately in our
communities a lot of young people don't
trust lawyers don't trust the system and
that's a very important part of that
process because a lot of young people
plead guilty immediately sometimes even
though they're innocent or maybe we feel
a case can be proven against them but
because of their fear that their system
is so unjust there's a lot of plea
bargaining and some of it again that
impacts our criminal justice system
we're a long ways with these cases again
referred to us by parents judges police
committee agencies educators in that
today we have the police in our schools
which I don't support we're getting
today
a kid to be coming be released on parole
all the time they say rather than
becoming a high school graduate and I
think that we all got well paying the
price now we're going to pay it even
heavier husband forward because I
educational system these certain letting
us down as it relates to elementary
junior and high school I have a lot of
kids that I deal with that are bright
that could be anybody they want but they
won't sit in a classroom the teachers
and I challenge and the problems in the
schools are enormous and our children
not getting the education they need and
given how things are going in this
country this is the workforce and where
are we going to be again generation from
now which is a concern so global being
known in the system we're able to
salvage and able to negotiate for a lot
of young people that live within the
lower side community where a program
originated of course I've been trying to
replicate into closer again in the
community that I can wear all these
problems exist and about 14 years ago I
took the program to East Harlem and I
created another branch to our agency
that's called a new global east harlem
project you know that again I'm a
believer that this work in this area has
to be done by community and and all the
stuff that I hire a living community
with our program operates which judges
understand and prosecutors understand
which is why unable to get young people
released out of the system that
traditionally would not be let out
because of the fear of our own system of
their legal cases are complicated of
course we're not just in the business or
getting kids out of jail and getting
criminal records and realistic we're the
same agency that may come back on a kid
that we got out who's not doing the
right thing so maybe bad dealing drugs
in a corner who decided not to address
the legal matter and we'll bring him
back to court which I think it's a very
important in lot of 80 is turning to
incarceration programs are coming to our
system as heroes meaning putting
together a package that a judge might
bite into but they don't want to deal
with the other side which i think is as
important as I in running this
organization concern myself Larry of
course what the young person who's
charged with the crime but I think we
need to take the victims into account in
the community and I've been well through
the years to share that concern across
the board and contains judges and
prosecutors that before we seal the deal
and sentence and lesion people two years
of incarceration with sometimes even
with costly notification and without it
we need to really look at the picture
closely and our end Oakland reserving to
communicate those messages and
fortunately there as I said you can
counter program super-bright choose
advocacy in one hand in our system and
we do this on a 24-hour base like I said
we hire people who live within the
neighborhood i'll also share with you
guys that the young lady sonia video
today is young woman is giving back she
works for me and she's one of my coat
advocates it's been working for me for
about a year
really terrific job now giving back as
you wanted to to the community of course
I am very concerned by policy and engage
with it through other organizations that
I supported on committees from the
Correctional Association is too many
others that are concerned about the
quality of our institutions whether
these juveniles or even a prison system
and of course we need more resources and
more people to tackle this issue as we
need more people to also be in the
trenches as I say we are courtrooms are
addressing kid by kid in case by case I
think it requires united effort of
policy people including and in
organizations that are truly involved in
making a difference in changing the
mindset in the criminal justice system
and I guess I'll leave you guys with
that thought and I'll answer any
questions you guys have an immediate
future
yes it is about your questions we're
gonna get to them in a second but i do
want to bring up been jealous because
here in the professor hearing angel both
giving you slices of what this reality
is obviously as the head of the
n-double-a-cp Ben sees this on a macro
level that really ties everything
together and I think it's worth getting
a little bit of introduction of the work
that he's doing there now as the
youngest man to take office and head it
at a time when the organization is
probably facing some of its biggest
challenges so interesting perspective
been kannamma Ben Jealous will good
afternoon it's good to be here with you
we want to thank mr. Cole for this great
program for young people at the college
is a graduate of college where something
like this was here when I was here and
it's it's it's just great to see a
company stepping out sort of beyond its
core business to recognize that really
what the core business of all of us as
citizens of this country should be as
building better communities in a better
country for all of us thank the
University for having me all of you for
being here and our new york state
conference is here as well great
hard-working volunteers trying to make
this the best state it can be but worry
about the problem from an academic
perspective and solutions from a
community service perspective both vital
the work that was just described is is
what it takes to turn communities in
crisis around person by person
individual by individual and people like
the young lady we saw on the screen
deserve that and more the for us as
people who come from many communities
will probably keep them steady or go
back to many states we also have to be
able to look at this at the national
level to really look at how do we
transform the country towards something
better than the day
are in right now because this is a dark
day in this country whether we
acknowledge it or see it or not and
quite frankly it's it's easy not to see
the problem of over incarceration
because people are behind prison walls
and prisons are typically in rural areas
where most of us don't spend much time
but if you look at it globally one thing
you'll notice is either 7 million
prisoners on earth and 2 million of them
are in our country we are not just the
world's leading incarcerated or black
people and brown people and we are
certainly that we it costs a black man
in this country today for examples five
times more likely to be incarcerated
than a black man in South Africa at the
height of apartheid and South Africa at
that time 20 years ago was the world's
leading incarcerated so we haven't just
taken over the pole position but we take
it to an entirely different level we've
lapped the field comes to incarceration
but also the world's largest most
frequent incarcerator of white people a
white man in America today is as likely
not five times more like black men but
as is as likely to be incarcerated as a
black man was in South Africa at the
height of a party in this moment the
Civil of human rights movement in this
country is much more about passing
legislation than about litigation and as
an organizer what that stat means
knowing there's about five times more
white men than black men in the country
is that we have roughly equal numbers of
black men and white men behind bars and
therefore roughly equal numbers of black
families and white families who have
been affected so we have to talk about
this problem of mass incarceration not
just with the sort of obvious linkages
to the segregated past but also in terms
of what it means as far as destroying
the unvisited future not just for the
black to the brown communities but for
the white community as well we've had
some success with this approach at the
nwacc p in the past year we've for
instance passed more than a dozen
progressive smart on crime criminal
justice reform bills in the state of
texas through a partnership with the tea
party not an explicit branded
partnership if you will but the folks in
the room when we organize who do they
represent that represented the Tea Party
in the n-double-a-cp the politician to
introduce the bill who are the primary
backers in the community the Tea Party
or the n-double-a-cp why really two
reasons one where I just talked about
poor working-class white folks are
deeply affected more deeply affected
than any other group of white folks on
the planet in this country you look at
the b-roll for the war on meth and it is
a film negative of the old b-roll from
the war on crack it used to be that you
would see the war on crack poor black
folks sitting on the Stoops in the
neighborhoods or outside of a housing
project now you see poor white people in
trailer parks those demographics are
real and people represent them and we
can organize those folks but also when
you look at the Tea Party they have
fiscal conservatives they have religious
conservatives and they have libertarians
now libertarians don't believe it you
should be in jail for anything that you
only did to yourself so they're pretty
easy to organize for instance and get
behind drug reform Christian
conservatives are outside the nation of
his Lobby other folks are most present
behind bars ministering to inmates and
they understand just how many families
were breaking up they understand what it
means when the number of women behind
bars skyrockets now because women are
killing their husbands more but because
they're using drugs and they're poor and
we send poor drug addicts to prison
that's what we do in this country and
that means their kids go to foster care
so the libertarians understand that it's
a legal nightmare the
concerns understand it's a moral
nightmare and the fiscal conservatives
understand that it's a financial
nightmare they listen to the other two
and they look at the problem and say
yeah well if drug rehab is seven times
more effective dollar for dollar than
incarceration for addicts why don't we
do more of the former and less of the
letter and so we got South Carolina to
go one two one on crack versus powder
eliminating the hundred times disparity
that just a few years ago men in South
Carolina if you were picked up caring
two walks two crappy would get the same
punishment as if you were carrying a
half kilo of powder something we
couldn't even get Nancy Pelosi's
Congress to do we only got them to go to
18 21 we got South Carolina going 121
working with the Tea Party got
Mississippi to go from 85-percent good
time I'm sorry eighty-five percent time
so requirement for nonviolent offenders
to a 25-percent time sir requirement
working with white conservatives and for
those of us who believe in human rights
that's what it has to look like we
cannot just stand here sort of
righteously and assume who our allies
are you have to look at the evidence see
where it leads you and organize the
people who can actually get the law
through to change the reality for all
the families represented by the story we
saw on the screen I'll close on this
years ago I was kicked out of Columbia
University for organizing student
protests she led 200 kids through a
second-story window over at low library
and I was on my way down to Mississippi
the governor had announced he was an
internal college into a prison
mississippi state valley mississippi
valley state university where jerry rice
had gone to school there was going to
make it a prison no more school to
Prison Pipeline to school to Prison
Pipeline required and so I was down to
for a while we were organizing big March
and we decided that it would be a shame
but you know it was so fundamentally
anti-american to turn a college into a
prison it would be a shame even in
Mississippi in the early 1990s for the
March to be all black folks and so we
were looking for white liberals in
Mississippi on short notice and we
realized that between that moment ember
march was Earth Day and we knew we could
find him on earth day if the white
liberals and make himself known in
Mississippi he would do it on earth day
and so we divided up teams we found out
to the various historically white
campuses you have the sore bleep black
colleges and Mississippian historically
white colleges that's all you got fanned
out their store of the white colleges
scheduled to speak on earth day now this
is back when cellphones were like the
size of a brick and none of us could
afford him and so my teams all check
back in around six o'clock but one team
with still out and I sit in my desk
waiting for the call and I fell asleep
at my desk and around two a.m. i got a
call waking me up my last team was
checking in they said been there's been
a problem of a mississippi state we we
need you to get down to the waffle house
you can see 275 pounds I had no problem
found the Waffle House I was there about
four and a half minutes
I got I got to the waffle as i sat down
with them they were going through this
whole the story about how they have been
threatened in Mississippi State first
they were told to wait till the very end
not speak at two of the other teams
that's pokemon 11 talking night when the
protests had turned to a keg party and
they finally after the third encore
Sweet Home Alabama let them speak at the
very fairy in the crowd was totally
drunk and my fellows got up and yelled
save the black colleges and the crowd
roared back get a row and they had done
the Mississippi two step which is you
walk just as fast as you can without
looking like you're afraid and run into
your car and then you drive us as fast
as you can without attracting the
attention the sheriff and then you drive
past all those bogs they've found all
those other black men's bodies before
they found Chaney Goodman and Schwerner
back to Jackson and as we're sitting out
at the table on a week when we had
gotten a lot of death threats and they
had talking about the threat they had
just received we realize an old white
guy was staring at us from the counter
he had a baggy shirt this is a state
that for a hundred bucks and no felonies
you can carry a firearm wherever you
want concealed however you want to
conceal it hanging down baggy shirt
hanging down you staring down it's real
mean he walked over to us it's too big
to go bags waffle houses there to create
human obesity that took go back to
grocery bags two big bags who walks over
us and he says all the boys haven't seen
on television now I'm from California
when got st. Louis up in Chicago who New
Orleans none of us are accustomed to
being called boy by some old white guy
and Mississippi three o'clock in the
morning but we realized the instance we
were the only black folks in the
restaurant so we said the only thing
that was reasonable in a week against
any death threat did you say yes sir he
said hold on a second he turned around
is putting down the bags we realized we
could no longer see his dominant hand
and two of the fellows with football
players and they're about to physically
restrain him because they were convinced
that the worst was about to happen and
as he spun around I said I'm just hold
on let's hear he has to say they gave me
a solid bet we might be dead by the time
he has to say what he has to say he
swung around we all watching his head in
slow-mo she said walls gonna shake your
because if I had been born a n-word in
this crazy state I'll be mad as heck to
know why y'all stop fighting back 25
years ago but I'm proud of you boys and
I want to help you so so if you need
anything if you need money if you need a
car well you just come see me Island the
used car lot right down highway 49 he
call this boy twice cost the n-word once
and yet our heart was Sir starting to
warm to the guy well the next morning I
sent those organizers down to get that
check from him I got paid 85 bucks a
week I needed to get paid but they
needed their faith in humanity restored
in a day before we had made two critical
mistakes we had assumed that we knew who
our friends were white folks at Earth
Day any time of day and your friends
definitely weren't the dude at the
counter staring at us baggy shirt in
this country this beautiful diverse
country in this country where people on
both sides of the aisle usually want to
believe they're doing the right thing in
this country where we can get nothing
done without a majority of votes let us
never assume that we know who our
friends are or who our friends aren't at
any given moment shirley Chisholm said a
long time ago we have no permanent
friends we have no permanent enemies we
just have permanent interests what stay
focus on the interests of making this
country a better place thank you and God
bless
okay potato has been set who's got the
first question who wants to blow up
something to discuss that goes to your
feelings about what it takes to organize
what the obstacles are in the community
what do you have so in the back excuse
me
I yes I was just curious as to
particularly angel how do you deal with
the anger that the kids in the community
have because a lot of the violence that
you see popping up I personally feel
that that's just um I think that's
justifiable anger just misdirected anger
how do you deal with that with the
people you were um misdirected anger is
correct I spent a lot of time with these
young people is how I do it almost on a
daily base I have centers that are open
to very late which enables young people
to come to us with many of those types
of issues and problems of course some of
it unrealistic as to what I do and again
i endu glover is a court advocacy
program that certainly challenges the
system to work out opportunities and so
I don't do anything everything for the
young person I'm certainly there for
them but I tap into a lot of resources
that are addressing some of the problems
of the young people are going through
from issues at home that create the
problems from issues at school that are
creating the problems from the issues in
there in a street with the gangs that
are creating the problems so I tap into
agencies that provide from therapy to
anger management and then I keep hands
on those issues to get the person to the
other side it's not a simple solution
and not an overnight process because
again the anger is embedded deep given
what's going on throwing in the city of
this country today can I answer them I
mean even thinking beyond the presence
of anger I worry about the absence of it
and in the community I study in Chicago
on the south side in particular there
was a lot of resignation and that
worries me more when perhaps the young
people who are the worst aw really don't
have any frame by which they understand
that things are really bad and so they
just say well the cop
you know they kind of pushed me around
but he didn't plant drugs on me so it's
cool you know like I could keep moving
and so there's the sense of resignation
I think should even be more worrisome
and our understandings of their world
their experiences and then why they
would advocate for change our would sort
of say something needs to be done
questions sir up front with the nametag
easily identifiable I was just wondering
if you guys could in a perfect world you
could wake up tomorrow and make
something happen what are say three
things that you feel like neat to change
for fundamental developments to take
place go ahead professor or go ahead
Ben's place to store with you then I'll
start with that i mean i'm not sure what
scared we're talking about so I you know
when we we have to be committed to being
a country in which everybody who wants a
job can find one we have to be committed
to being a country that believes that
all the kids are all our kids getting
beyond all the adjectives in this
country that we place before we say that
child that poor black child that poor
white child now there's all our kids and
that means finally what we have to make
sure that every child can go to a good
school with a great teacher in every
classroom I I agree started with those
issues
it's again it's complicated i wish that
i had a magic wand that i could make our
educational system better and again i
relate to not so much as a national
issue though it is national it's our
communities and in acidic communities
are falling by the wayside when it comes
to education i wish that i could provide
a mother and father to every one of my
children many of our children are being
unfortunately developed by a single
parents usually mothers are in my
scenario that i see a lot is I got
grandparents that are 70 years old
addressing this 15 16 year olds and it's
not possible of course you know in the
best world to have to be able to get
young people employed and because it is
about money and it's about that kind of
support for that and I don't want to be
repetitive but in thinking about seeing
all children as our children and
providing them education I think
internally just really developing a
sense of self and worth that then isn't
shut down once you sort of confront the
outside world and so working from the
kind of internal build up of self esteem
self efficacy and then changing the way
in which the world sees you sort of like
do voices concept of double
consciousness like seeing oneself
through the eyes of others and
unfortunately it's often contemptuous
but maybe it could be positive maybe it
could be much more you know enlightening
for development and then beyond that
having opportunity like education like
employment etc I have a follow-up
question there's going to be beat me
with your hand the title is advocating
for a just community right just as a
tricky word because it makes you think
justice and here's one of the
difficulties that each of you has to
deal with in your own way if it will
justice basically defined as fairness
under law you have a difficulty that
someone like you professor you're trying
to make people understand what gets
these kids let's leave the adults out
for a second what gets these kids to
grow up in
that they're susceptible to a criminal
justice system more than they should be
their condition to it the condition to
see themselves the other side is
law-breaking fairness under law you
actually did it it was wrong the
penalties wherever it happens seems to
happen more here that creates friction
with change right for each of you angel
then when you try to get people behind
certain causes you will get pushback
well they committed a lot of crime so
this community committed a lot of crimes
these kids you want us to give a second
chance to did really bad things these
people you want us to understand do bad
things that we don't see in our better
communities may be wider communities so
help me understand that here help me
angel understand what the reality is of
who the kid is who's coming regardless
of what they did and then bend some
perspective about what you say to
somebody when they come to you with that
level of resistance please I mean at the
beginning you would think you know is
this justice being evenly distributed
and we have to acknowledge like at what
points of the system if we're talking
about a system where everyone should be
equal under law what's happening at each
stage and so I think it would take a
concerted effort to really mark the
pathways into the system and what's
happening with people once they perhaps
present themselves with the same offense
but then take different trajectories so
I think we'd have to work on the kind of
unpacking the black box of the justice
system to see what are the mechanisms by
which we're processing these people
through the system and then it's that
done in a just way and if we get to even
where that's happening we then should
still be thinking about the symptoms
that bring people to the system so the
judge so don't seem as the crime black
box double entendre yeah but
then we're saying also that what we do
with poor drug addicts for instance
women they go to jail what happened to
the ones they don't out on the extrema
lindsay lohan white and rich celebrity
but where's them between so that's
that's how we see them don't see them as
the crime scene as how got him there so
angel you have to deal with it a
different way you present me with the
kid they're tatted up I hear about these
horrible list of things they've done
you're saying second chance there's
going to be some resistance for people
who didn't come out of a similar
scenario how do you explain through it
to make them understand why second
chance is worthy is relevant is needed
we you know we're prosecuting kids in
New York and now it's across the country
as adults when a 14 and 15 euro just to
take that population who are you at 14
I'm sure you all have brothers and
sisters or children that are 14 years
old and while I engage in creating that
part in New York which is the model
that's now across the city and the
country we still question the fact
whether we're doing the right thing to
prosecute 14 and 15 year olds adult and
hold them to an adult standard what are
they thinking in a courtroom after they
take this plea which some judge is
saying you're looking at jail you're
looking a criminal record and what is
that young man or a young girl thinking
that young boy young girl may also be
the same person who's involved in drugs
you might have been arrested already
three times for possession or for evil
intent to sell I again I'm in a system
trying to educate judges on 121 base and
prosecutors that it has to be a
different way we need to look at the
whole picture we need to look at where
this kid is coming from what's happened
to him that led to this stage and in
four Andruw glover what we try to do is
to custom then tailored services for
that kid around many of those issues we
may incorporate placing him in a
different home and may incorporate a
drug program upstate that i have to set
forward in order to give the judge or
the DA something to have
hat on it is actually what the kid needs
in order to show that you weren't at a
second opportunity and ironically what
works in favor for you is that all of
those who are working within that system
know that their system doesn't work that
that kids not going to come out any
better and any likelihood so that
carries us into you mr. jealous you're
coming you're looking at a community the
the obvious push back that you're going
to see on a bigger level is everybody
needs stuff Ben you're coming to me you
want to help this group they're kind of
guilty of their own situation you know
right especially when you're dealing
with bigger political forces the easiest
thing with brush aside is someone's own
responsibility for what you're trying to
fix but what's what's missing in the
dialogue when you get that kind of
resistance you're saying now you're
dealing with the Tea Party trying to
find any kind of constituency that you
can to get some type of inroads and to
change its at all obstacles especially
today money's tight people are angry
yeah and yet we waste so much money in
the criminal justice system but there's
always money to be found if you're
willing to do things that are smart and
not just tough they give me an example
we Detroit Davis case high-profile
definitely case we're very involved has
renewed conversation about abolishing
the death penalty it looks like
Connecticut and Maryland could do it
very soon and that's where sort of the
conversation about justice is most raw
all right you're talking to a victim's
family for instance about you want to
balash the death penalty and really in
their mind they just want to see the
person that hurt their family and killed
their loved one dead also when you give
this conversation about resources and no
criminal justice system how to be
spending on what are we getting for it
and what we found is that with victims
families if once they understand that
seeking the death penalty costs 500,000
to a million dollars more than seeking
life without the possibility of parole
and they understand that any given
community thirty to seventy percent of
homicides go unsolved and so they
understand that the the choice for the
criminal justice system is do we
and 500,000 to a million dollar seeking
the ultimate punishment for the next
killer or do we use that money and give
it to the homicide department to hire
more homicide detective to get more
killers off the street even the victims
families tend to go for that option life
without parole plus the savings going to
get more killers off the street rather
than the death penalty and the money
going to kill the guy who we already got
off the street how often do you see when
you're pushing that argument that state
legislators stay away from life
imprisonment without parole because they
don't want to lose the political
currency of the attractiveness of the
death penalty that's that's where your
father is an inspiration to all of us
right because you know in the years he
was governor 75 or some of the people in
the state supported the death penalty
and he just wouldn't do it that's why I
got his ass boot out in 1994 12 years
that's a bit too pretty to run the you
know the the reality is there something
that's you know it is there are a
handful of state legislators in any
state and even one probably a handful of
das that this is what they make their
career on it's really that second
explicit you look at any state in the
country and it's always like I think you
know less than seven counties in that
state that sent half the image to death
row and so you're really talking about
seven DA's careers and that's you know
that that's the brutal thing about this
country you talk about you had
definition of justice that's one
definition that's a lawyer's definition
of justice or a legal definition this
country is such a in 44 was real it was
a real matter of faith when sparbers
kind of catholic remove them the
doctrine of life right so this kind of
such a church-going country that most
people's notion of justice is more of a
divine notion of justice fairness what's
right what's wrong and even when you can
get folks to focus and they say okay so
you know they use a crack they think
black person they point out to them that
black people are fifteen percent of the
crack users white people are 65 Blacula
eighty-five percent people locked up for
low-level position what
people are five percent people locked up
for low-level position level possession
it's pretty hard for them not to admit
that someone's broken and then have a
choice on their hands we can either go
after that that's sixty-five percent of
the crack eggs whether we've gone after
the fifteen percent in release in a
criminal justice system through the roof
where we can admit that maybe what's
been working with the sixty-five percent
which is rehab could work for the
fifteen percent and that's that's been
working for us in state after state hmm
the social pressure of the desire to
punish versus the desire to fix yeah
it's a tricky thing ma'am hello how are
you hello mr. Rodriguez it's in order to
see you on this panel I currently have a
question I have family that live in East
Harlem and I've known about the other
Glover program for some time and my
question is and I have a major concern I
actually am an advocate also for family
for northern mahan and this bike of
young men having guns and shooting has
become something that every time I turn
around and I turn on the TV it's just
scares me and my question is to you
angel and to the panel what is being
done and why are so many young people
getting their hands on guns I just don't
understand it so can somebody maybe give
me an answer to that I have a program in
his column and I'm also again very much
concern about what's happening in our
communities across the board but he's
taught him in particular I think you and
I know that the projects are all at war
with each other
as you know last weekend there was a big
conference all day addressing will be
boarding young people to talk about
what's going on and why is this
happening in this again this goes back
to the question earlier there's a lot of
anger within a lot of these young people
today that again are revolting with
weapons and again people are getting
killed and a little disappointed in that
I've been talking about gangs for the
last 20 years to some of our local city
people and City Council and some of the
captains are some of the presents and
everyone has ignored it to the point
that today it's a serious problem that
we are living which it tributes to a lot
of these violence is going on I went to
a police meeting recently in my own
community where I was very concerned and
verbal about the fact that this issue is
coming from a lot of the gang scenarios
and a white shirt of administrator from
the police department sort of turned to
me and said to our faces that they don't
think it's a gang problem and that kind
of ignorance I think it's a real issue
for us all because it's not there's an
outcry for the community itself to come
out and to talk about these issues and
to you know drop a dime on people who
are committing the crimes mayor has
screamed out for that yet in that
dissent agree happens but the
community's powerless and we really need
for all these experts and people to come
in and and try to address this issue
from those perspectives again I said in
that way because I unfortunately we all
are put in positions where we're kind of
everyone is so separate so that I'm I'm
in the trenches of the criminal justice
trying to deal with what's happening
they're of course that runs into the
street which is why I'm concerned and
know what's going on and I am a little
concerned about on police departments
I've been screaming bloody murder my own
community in areas where there's a lot
of these issues going on why not put an
officer in that corner who can deter
some of these kids in East Harlem we got
116 110 120 fifth you guys need to go
there when it starts to get dark it is a
different world and yet we don't see the
police department we see them when a
crime happens and they come in to pick
up the pieces and perhaps make the Iraq
it's a cycle right though because of the
officers as you know whether they want
to say it or not they're afraid to go
because of the high incident ratio
because they know the buns are there not
only that we have a lot of young
officers who many I don't think know our
streets that leads to some of the most
outrageous incidents that have happened
in our city where I mean you guys know
about these cases where you know 50
bullets are fired into a car mostly
because these officers are kind of
panicked and scared and I used to appear
at work all might be simply try to
sensitize these officers and while we
did this for a couple of years I'm not
summoned anymore to do any of those
things just like the legal aid society
would call me to educate their attorneys
about a Turner to incarceration programs
and they don't incorporate any of those
issues in their trainings anymore call
it a lack of money or lack of concern
i'm not sure where that lies and it's
very problematic i think to all of us
and we're paying the price to two quick
things one with regards to two officers
what's far more effective in sensitivity
training is personality tests you
actually give them on the front end you
weed out the bullies there's a very high
ratio most departments within people who
were schoolyard bullies and people were
in out cops and you don't want them to
be cops if you don't want people to be
shot unnecessarily and those this is a
city called Rockford Illinois
for instance embraced these in the wake
of one of their officers shooting an
unarmed black man in a church in front
of daycare kids and that officer they
had to admit was really the shooting
problem the town was that officer and
they finally got him off the court force
they could have avoided that with a
simple personality test the front end
with regards to the problem of violence
of the community the the number that we
should be paying attention to that we
tend to neglect is the homicide case
closed rate it's it's issued by the FBI
every year for major cities we in city
should be insisting that it's issued for
every neighborhood while this is you
have what percentage the murders go
unsolved every year you might have a
city what's fifty percent going saw but
you have a neighborhoods ninety percent
and that's why the officers are afraid
because they know that ninety percent
think the killers are on the streets in
that neighborhood so so how do we deal
with that we get back to beat officers
it is interesting experiment down in San
Francisco to neighborhoods Bayview in
the Tenderloin both high homicide rates
the Tenderloin because it also has some
nice restaurants in one edge of it was
able to convince the police department
to put officers on the street to walk
the beat and the comma side case closed
right gap just disappeared because
people who have information often want
to give it but they're not going to walk
over to your cruiser and flag you down
and give it to you but if they know that
you walk past that block every day
around two o'clock go wait in the alley
do you walk by the pull you in the alley
they'll tell you you'll be on your way
and you'll know who killed him so its
your game back to old fashioned policing
is shifting priorities all these crazy
stop and frisk we do are just just
window dressing they ruin kids lives
they don't make us any safer it take all
those people hours all those cop hours
shift them over to people walking
walking the beat and focusing on
homicides you'll see the killer's come
off the streets you'll see the violence
level go down sir
oh okay all right thank you all for all
the work that you do and thank you for
all the things that you've shared I
actually want to sort of adult a little
deeper my name is Cecil Corbin mark I
help run a an environmental justice
organization that's located here in
Harlem and we do work in Harlem and
Washington Heights it's we act for
environmental justice and I could take
this whole sort of criminalization and
why rising levels of violence are going
up around that sort of toxic chemicals
route but I won't do that I'll I was
fear that conversation for now but one
of the things that was interesting sort
of the academic perspective the
community perspective in the sort of
national / Ben comes from I think
all of that that you all said was
critically important but not much and it
just started to come out of this tail
end here was really focused on the
institution's themselves and what are
their missions and how are they aligned
and should they not be given different
missions especially when it comes to
kids right I think that the Dinkins
administration here in the city
attempted to do some of that stuff when
they brought back the beat officers and
sort of tried to realign and create this
whole notion of community policing but
to me that requires a vision ship a
different mandate for what police
officers are out on the street to do not
just the officers but what the entire
apparatus of the police department is
supposed to do visa vie young people in
our street if their mission and focus is
all about sort of calm stats and how
many people have we arrested and how
many people and the focus is on those
numbers and the crime outcomes right or
just reducing crime without looking at
some of these underlying issues then
they're not agencies that are supporting
the growth development and future life
smart kids right they're doing something
that they're supposed to be doing by
their mission which is locking people up
and shutting people
so if we could get a little more talk
about sort of mission realignment and
getting these institutions to see their
role in nurturing the next generation in
nurturing healthy children I think that
would be an important part out of this
conversation as well well flip flip it
around angel and start by answering with
the perspective of why you think they're
not that way right because the reality
is the local police forces rusev by
precinct more or less aren't in the
child nurturing business right they
could be but they're not why not yeah
well again we have our own problems I
believe that the police department every
four or five years quoting the number
there there's a shift of the captains
and I think their lives part of the
problem we and of course we also this
country and again I speak of the city is
always trying to be innovative in a mare
goes to Europe comes back and designs
our streets and sets up things that are
problematic I think to the people cost a
lot of money in in this case the
policing of officers are is in it is
something that works but again we're
talking about a time when there is no
money and when you talk to the police
department these are the things that
they come up with aside from the fact
that every time that you get things in
place in our community where something
is working where this captain
understands the problem that's happening
in this particular park on this
particular community and agrees that we
need to have a bead officer there it's
just like the highway if you put a
police car in a highway you'd be
guarantee not to have people speeding
the car is empty but as soon as you see
that call you throw your brakes and
everybody slows down on the line
unfortunately like I said a system is
set forward that officer may agree may
start working with the community to put
these things in place and before he gets
a real chance to activate and put this
in place he shifted not to another
precinct new captain comes in he doesn't
like that guy's ideas so now we're
inventing the wheel lover again and I
think
we continue to beat ourselves is my
experience again and I'm I relate more
to to what's happening on our streets
and our immediate presents and so that's
the political component in fact
political turnover what about the
professor bless your bed the what about
what about what you're looking at in
terms of by way of example and then you
explain this example most big city
police forces you go to you say what's
the first thing you guys will cut in
your budget they'll say before manpower
yes perform in a community sports
outreach goes first it's the first thing
that we see we can go and they say and
it's the worst thing to cut what does
that inform you of in terms of how they
see what their role is versus what the
realities of what it could be yeah the
person who asked the question you
mentioned the relationships and the
ability to nurture and really having
that orientation and I think it goes
back to web and jealous said about
figuring out who we're hiring to be cops
and then using these people to
facilitate positivist create positive
relations with the people they police so
I worried a bit when both of you said oh
put more beat officers out there but
that could make a situation seem more
ominous or it can open it up where kids
in particular feel protected and they
have a relationship I've done many
interviews with young people where they
talk about how they hate police they
don't trust them they don't respect them
and at the end of the interview we're
walking down the hallway and it's like
oh wassup officer Flores give me a
dollar and you know uncle so-and-so and
I'm just like wait I thought she didn't
like police and it's like but I like
Uncle officer Flores like he's different
and so it's the relationship that this
young person was able to build with the
police officer and for young people who
say well I know her from my project
building and she's embedded in the
grammar school I go to this right next
door to the project building and she
knows my family so it really was about
the relationships and the interactions
that was key so when you take out the
you know opportunities for these
particular types of off the you know
legal beat interactions then you take
away the kind of positive possibilities
of mission is important it needs to be
tied to incentive I mean think about
this right so this morning I was on my
way up here I couldn't be my daughter's
grade school she was receiving an award
for reading she's the best reader in her
class now she's in kindergarten and last
year they in a pre-k she was distraught
because two other girls could read in
the class and she couldn't read so we
we've spent 20 minutes a day with her
ever since kind of helping her learn to
read and that she's the best reader in a
class talk about prisons for a second
not police seventy-five percent of
people who go into prison are two
illiterate to read the menu at mcdonalds
seventy-five percent will come out of
prison or two illiterate to read the
menu at mcdonalds some of those folks
have been there for 20 years how is it
like what is their mission now if their
mission is to correct to make better
than one of the easiest ways to measure
that would be to improve literacy but
what if prison guards received an
incentive for the literacy rate of the
inmates inside their prison I guarantee
you they would find 20 minutes in the
day to help those guys learn how to read
and they would come out at least being
able to read the menu at mcdonalds means
maybe they could get a job there two
questions young lady make the microphone
holder work or our girls no no no so
everybody has a role here that's what
that's what community organizing is all
about don't touch the microphone don't
touch
my name is Chicago that I work at
Community League of the heights in
Washington Heights and one thing that we
do is we work with a middle and high
school in the area that are under our
auspice and we've heard a lot about the
police and the politics but I'm
wondering especially from angels
perspective what can we teach the kids
to get them out of that system before
they even get into it or what can we
give them in terms of tools that will
allow them to advocate for themselves as
I look it stated earlier that I mostly
spend my time in the courthouse dealing
with again a lot of young people charged
with all kinds of different things I'm
also involved with the preventive side
which I think it's as important so if
you go to one of my centers but you'll
see is again some kids that are indicted
who have deferred sentencing that we're
trying to earn wire on probation and get
kids right back to mainstream where they
need to be but as again being in a
community trying to educate a kid who
have not yet cross those lines in order
to do that it take it's taking us into
the home of these kids because the
problems begin at home with a lot of
these young people the lack of
supervision of the lack of you know
spending 20 minutes she kid how to read
or or do his assignment of do his
homework so it's it's a for me it's
complicated we do it by getting very
close to these kids trying to understand
the
needs and then the custom tailored some
of the things they need from again
therapy are addressing the issue that
the father's not there and the kid is
feeling it the fact that again the
living with grandparents who can't take
care of them and is spending time on the
street so it the way that we do it is by
spending time on the street with these
kids and trying to gather them and
trying to get them off the street to
provide safe space for them and direct
them to the right places it's
complicated i wish that i had a magic
wand you know as i said he judges and
prosecutors rehabilitation given some
other orientation and damages done early
to this kit it's not an overnight
process so the fact that again i can
turn a kid around that committed two
armed robberies it's not going to happen
from one day to the next when he's been
living a particular lifestyle but has to
be addressed almost every day by getting
again mentors and counselors and people
in their lives that care and that can
guide them in different ways questions
your discussion of this children and
incarceration is very interesting I'm
just wondering if there is any incentive
to reduce the prison the student to
Prison Pipeline when prisons provide
such an enormous labor market there is
not just a prison guards their laundry
food industries the telephone i heard
recently that verizon was hooked to the
prison system transportation there's a
whole economy built around the prison
system and i'm wondering if there's any
incentive not to have student who i have
heard in new york state the prison
system is generated off of the test
scores for grade for they can count the
track the number of beds that will be
available to in 10 years yeah yes okay
but that same industry a prison is
providing a lot of people with income
and labor who have a pension and alt and
unemployment so what kind of incentive
would it be to not track people from the
fourth grade and put them in an industry
where so many people who don't look like
the kids who are going dear are provided
with an income and a salary and benefits
if you could just address that Alec so
you know New York is actually steadily
decreased its incarceration rate over
the last couple of decades it's one of
the few states in the country that has
the report that was referenced by the
professor misplaced priorities we put
out less Springs worth is worth looking
at so it can be done it is being done
easily done faster we've been able to
make common when we release that report
misplaced priorities which was about how
in state after state as spending on
incarceration has gone up
spending on public universities has come
down Ground Zero California when I was a
kid there three percent of the state
budget went to prisons and eleven
percent to public universities and now
eleven percent goes to public
universities and 7.5 percent to sorry
now eleven person goes to prisons and
7.5 percent to public universities so
its flipped you know or Pennsylvania
where the president Penn State will tell
you his big a struggle every years keep
money out of the state pen so I can come
to Penn State it can be done when we
released a report we had the president
of the California prisons guards Union
the CCPO a the largest prison guardian
in the country released the report with
us his guards have been working 20 hours
of mandatory overtime for more than five
years they're exhausted they don't want
any more prisons what they want our jobs
in drug rehab drug rehabilitation
facilities drug we have facilities and
frankly safer places for them to work
they be happier working there and they
now understand that the state would be
better off but you know these these
folks you can have to look at them
holistically you can't just look at it
far as one other entrances that you have
multiple interests yes they're out of
prison working as a prison guard a
member of a union that's part of the
life they're also typically in that
union doing that really tough nasty job
because they have kids who they want to
see a better opportunities and at the
point that it became clear that the
expansion of their own industry was a
direct opposition to the children's
realization of their dreams because
California the big dreams is to send
your kids to the public university
system the prison guard actually Union
began to change their politics and say
you know what we're bigger than we need
to be we can shrink the size of this
system we can create this other system
over here that will actually make
everybody better off drug rehabilitation
industry and we can spend less money at
it which means that the schools our kids
are hoping to go to will be better kids
are better opportunities so you have to
be able to ultimately get people to
recognize that they have more than one
interest and you can actually make great
progress professor let's do closing
statements from each of your professor
will store with you I think history is
important with the kind of
transformation of going from slavery to
the abolition of slavery saw the prison
plantations that grew up from there and
Jim Crow and then the explosion of the
prison system posts 70s and 80s to what
we have now to think about what's
happening with immigration policy and
the filling of people in detention
centers you know that used to fulfill
this prison need we have a lot of work
to do in kind of addressing the base
level inequalities in people's you know
housing options school options
employment options and all of these you
know deficits in these areas are what is
feeding the kind of prison system and
incarceration rate that we're seeing
moving forward so we do have a lot to do
on the front end instead of you know
then addressing the back end once people
are already lost so I hope people are
energized to keep working at this an
angel were keeping you from doing that
work right now but please give us a
closing yeah well you know as it relates
in New York City or least in an area
that I'm in I'm not seeing less
incarceration I see more we got a new ta
certainly in Manhattan that came aboard
with a platform or potentially helping
systems not to be as loaded as they are
and I don't see it happening on a one to
one case as I address it I don't know if
you guys know that correction is a
business and their towns upstate that
used to not want these prisons and after
a certain point they wanted these
institutions because these institutions
who are bringing millions of dollars of
revenue into these towns so they're more
than welcome in these prisons even
though there is a lot of work being done
to close down some of these institutions
as they started dressing hopefully
alluring that number
incarceration and so I believe that
people need to start start looking also
at the ground level and I'm talking
about what's happening in a DA's office
that I think even though New York City
for example we have like five different
cities in that every every borough has a
different da and not da sort of creates
the mandate as to how that operates of
course the laws are the same but their
procedures and process and can be very
different and a lot of it leads to
incarceration mr. jealous thank you um
let say is this you know we were found
in the city a hundred and two almost 103
years ago when this nation and the city
in this country were in a much worse
place in many ways on many issues our
founders were audacious enough to
believe that things can be made much
better if they focused on waging battles
over decades and not over months or
years and it worked pretty well in many
ways obviously there's a lot more that
needs to be done and so I would
encourage people here to just take a
moment in the next week just just write
down a list of all the things you would
like to see change before you die which
most cases will be decades from now and
then pick one that you're really going
to invest yourself and change doesn't
have to be the best one honestly if you
got a list of 10 things you can't figure
out what's the best one close your eyes
point out one lift that the only thing
that beats waiting to find the best one
is seizing one of the good ones right
now and focus on changing that one thing
I work every day with a woman who was 16
years old decided that that was going to
be ending the juvenile death penalty in
this country and before she was 25 years
old she had done it she was the lead
organizer she was South Carolina black
from South Carolina she was the lead
organizer in South Dakota Wyoming in New
Hampshire the only states that we passed
those bands in the last three states
that we had to before
we went to the Supreme Court and it was
all because she made a choice when she
was 16 that she was going to focus I'm
changing one thing before she died she
did it before she was 25 it was a
problem we had in this country for
hundreds of years there was no reason
why she should even think that she could
have done it in decades but because she
focus on it she convince others to do it
including myself we got it done and
that's what we each need to do if we
want to see our country get better and
better thank you to each of you for the
perspective thanks for letting me be
here with you and thank you for joining
us and the questions thank you all thank
you Chris for moderating and cuddlin
angel and Bend thank you so much we're
going to take just a brief break about
15 minutes before our next pot panel on
social media and social change so we
will see you back in just a few thank
you